gardera durablement les traces de ce
cyclone qui est réputé le plus important
depuis une quinzaine d'années l'économie
locale et déjà fragile elle repose
essentiellement sur l'aide de la
métropole et de la communauté européenne
gros plan sur une économie en sous
perfusion elle ne décolle toujours pas
les antilles françaises importe beaucoup
plus qu'elle ne produise
philippe rudare la guadeloupe un
ensemble économique déjà fort
déséquilibre est en crise permanente et
qui vient de toute évidence d'être mise
à mal une nouvelle fois les
exploitations agricoles traditionnelle
canne à sucre et banane ray sont
détruites à 100% les prochaines récoltes
ne viendront pas il en sera de même pour
la production d'ananas industries de
transformation de ces production
agricole devra faire relâche pour les
salariés cela se traduira par du chômage
par contre les activités de pêche et
d'aquaculture la transformation du bois
devrait pouvoir reprendre assez
rapidement
conséquence beaucoup plus difficile à
envisager dans les activités de
transformation essentiellement générée
par des entreprises de petite et de
moyenne dimension la grande faiblesse du
tissu économique guadeloupéen
c'est l'absence d'industries véritable
que l'artisanat en revanche assez
développés ne parvient pas à compenser
troisième secteur le secteur tertiaire
dans lequel les activités de
distribution et de tourisme se taille la
part du lion d'un ensemble conférant à
lille une apparence de développement
de conception récente et infrastructures
touristiques le semble avoir tenu le
coup reste à savoir si les touristes
métropolitains des américains honoreront
cette année leur réservation
il faut le souhaiter car depuis une
dizaine d'années le tourisme est devenu
en quelque sorte le poumon de la
guadeloupe
les investissements ayant été multipliés
grands hôtels et gîtes ruraux affiche
complet
cette année le fait de passer des
vacances en guadeloupe sera une marque
significative de solidarité